hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play surgeon
simulator 2013 okay there was a recent
update that added no that's wrong then
added a few space missions to this as
well as another extra surprise that I'm
going to get to if I can beat these but
there is now a kidney in space one that
it says I already did but I know I
haven't because I checked and I didn't
unless I know this is new this is what
they said to me it was new it's been a
while since I picked up my old surgeons
tools let's see if I still have a knack
for this I still got it cutting into
people's flesh ripping them apart from
the inside out pulling their intestines
out through their anus yeah pretty much
like riding a bike for me the
professional Nigerian doctor criterion I
don't think that's where I was from but
I'll go with it yeah they kicked me out
of Nicaraguan doctoring school so I had
to go to Nigeria in order to be able to
get them I had this email from a prince
who said he could give me a lot of money
so I trusted him and he got me this
great doctorate degree I mean I'm really
happy with the no no no no no no no no
no no come on cooperate with me
cooperate with me Bob cooperate with me
just a little bit more there we go all
right Bob it looks like your knees are
out through your anus or no that's the
wrong definition your knees not your
knees your ribcage hello
so this could have come flying back on
me well isn't that just lovely
now if only I could pull the rest of
that out but that appears to not be
cooperating gives me saw I need you more
than ever
alright fine be that way go to hell and
die for all I care
I need it okay so as I remember how long
has this been here and how if I ignored
it for so long I have no idea let's see
how well it works not well at all
because I can't swing it
I can't there is no way to swing this
man maybe like chopping motion like this
let's see good job I got the lever
pretty good there but not the intestines
which is what I'm going for
no that didn't work either it was an
easy way to do this right now that I
recall something easier what's that you
say it's something smaller but but I
always go bigger bigger is always better
ax you don't belong in the intestines
get out of there ax do I even have one
scalpel left here we go oh there we go
okay so now that we've got the scalpel
we can just easily slice through that
like butter the scalpel actually is
quite effective how strange an actual
sturgeons tool is good it's surgery nice
wha what is this black magic that I see
in my heart ah whoa wait whoa whoa whoa
it came right at me
it came right at me you son of a [ __ ]
get out of there you're not required on
the operating floor we're kind of in
space so I don't know if we actually
have a floor anymore but whatever okay
gotta get Timmy they get that is that
new music by the way that sounds
different than anything I've seen before
maybe it's just a space music and I
haven't heard in in a while
I don't know either way it's pretty cool
I like it okay now if this liver is
gonna cooperate which it's not because
it's tucked in behind those damn ribs
that refused to die and that saw is
gonna drive me insane and this guy's
bleeding out so okay let me just let me
have let me just let me just intestines
please excuse me intestines really gonna
be like that God it happened it happened
oh my god you got to be kidding me
oh you got to be joking me oh it's gone
it's gone forever he'll never come back
I'm operating here don't you see that I
know what's best okay let's see if I can
jab myself repeat non hallucinogenic
there we go okay much better now my
patient is still bleeding out rather
rapidly let's see if I can hurry up here
and get this thing to just cut off this
last vestige of rib get it there we go
okay god it's out of there don't set you
down very gently and gingerly feeling
just grab this liver and just rip it out
with my bare bloody hand hey man maybe
this is gonna be okay maybe he's not
gonna die in about ten seconds from
total system failure and blood loss
oh no it's gonna be like this again all
I've got is an ear swab your swab don't
fail me now it's okay Bob I know you're
about to bleed to death but Bob just
calm down Bob you go crazy go crazy on
me Bob well spinning intestine just uh
yeah that's normal that's settle down
there you look like a raw chicken just
floating through space just ah here have
these noodles Bob
Bob just eat your damn noodles and get
it over with
come on Bob Bob Bob oh no I lost another
one okay Pat again well that sucked
let's see I need to get better at
getting this damn rib out because that
was it those are caused the problem in
the first place
gingerly I got you I can't believe I got
you okay whoa whoa whoa all right
this'll work
that's working it's working baby oh it's
working so good oh yeah get it get it
get some of that hit that rib out of
there yeah that's a stump okay even
though there seems to be catastrophic
damage going on here I think it's gonna
be okay
cuz this guy is not gonna die on me
gives me where did my Oh don't touch it
okay
ha ha ha ha ha bass ackwards into the
intestines get it okay I didn't need
that watch anyway okay right the face
the eye is the exact point where you
want to inject the hallucinogenic narco
tropic oka tropic drugs oh my god he's
gonna die no how did he get down so low
there we go okay now Bob just stay not
dying just stay alive for a little bit
longer I'm going to cut your intestines
out of your body and then replace your
kidneys with these artificially
constructed objects got it Oh God and
I've got that wait no if I can grab this
scalpel here Bob
ah it's just out of my range okay let's
try this no oh that's my only scalpel
okay
it's gently like a melet whoa hi mr.
Simms drilled things off got that put
that out there I don't think I have
enough blood to make it I don't think
I'm gonna make it I'm not gonna make it
am i oh my god this is all gonna be for
naught
oh you all remember how good I am at
this game right mr. drill seriously did
you did you f off please to the edge of
space fall into oh my god II know he was
gonna die holy crap
one minute 54 point 191 seconds Jesus
how did he do I need to calm down
he's I need to slam some of these pills
here but no time for that
can gently get the saw because then no
God whoa Jason the song I've gone crazy
I've gotten space crazy oh my god what
the hell happened okay I'm gonna just
pretend like that never happened both OH
what the hell happened there everybody
but wow this is why I don't condone
doing surgery in space got it okay now
just get the ribs ever so gently it
doesn't cause blood loss if I only touch
the ribs I know this I've learned this
from the past I've done this before I
swear I'm not a bad doctor I'm just a
doctor from Nigeria wok WA I'm just a
doctor from some country that starts
with N and don't ask me which one
because it's a very highly reputable one
oh man
it doesn't go away if I don't get this
sternum out of the way
let me just chip away at the sternum
there okay it should be enough
I should never need that saw again so if
it goes flying back into the body I'm
gonna be very upset
can you tell me what is going to piss
mark choir off the most this game you
are correct sir what an astute
observation
okay those kidney whoa no god damn it Oh
mother Humber you are there we go okay
got that Oh
kidney you better not fly out of it we
closed the lid on that son of a [ __ ]
and just stay the Frick get no no no no
no don't get it stay in there good
enough you better be that when I turn
back
did you better not don't mess with me
bro not in the mood for any of your bull
I'm not holding all of that am i oh come
on uh-oh it's spinning I'm gonna catch
it I'm gonna catch Wow probably by the
blade Ian white how does this help me
they turned it that way through my hand
back that way you have it no I do not
have it son of a [ __ ] bookie dog okay
the anger I remember why I stopped
playing this game the anger the eternal
burning rage inside my soul okay do I
have this one I do
the unending Regents that burns within
me oh come on I need a better grip on
that yeah happy sticky all right there
we go I don't think this is gonna be the
good angle about whatever I make do with
what I have because I'm a doctor and a
damn good one too
like come on cooperate with me oh come
on don't dig into the intestines like
that how is that gonna help anyone it
certainly isn't gonna help Bob live and
happy life and go back to his family in
space
you know yeah no no oh god really oh
wait no there's a scalpel right here how
long has this one been here yeah okay it
it looks like I have it but I don't but
whatever I'm going for it okay just get
in there just dig in there and oh really
oh really
really really really now the scalpel is
inside the intestines what the hell god
damnit mother perjur'd Ablett's God so
much that would justify gently massage
your intestines like this you like that
Bob you like it you like it you like it
what dr. house did on an episode and
sized the intestines just squeeze out
some goop nah what does this do
I don't even know but this looks like it
might be good okay it's long definitely
longer flex oh my god this thing is
amazing
what haven't I been using this the
entire time I've seen this too I just
didn't know it was far fur get out of my
face I don't even know what that was but
I don't want it in my face
please I'm a professional haha the
intestines have finally erupted from the
cavity Oh get off of my fingers and the
scalpel has gone free to go back in
frolic in the woods there deserves okay
still isn't quite the right angle but
I'm not letting go of this sumbitch my
life depends on it because this this is
this is good this is good right here
ahh I got you out of there and get that
looks like that got severed that
connection on that old kidney and the
other kidney is already dead so let's
just feel again oh oh my god who's
disgusting oh yeah okay see if we can
excise the liver here without oh he's
bleeding out fast I don't even think I
have the green one of any more so I'm
just gonna have to yeah I don't know
where the green one went but it went
away forever
where did it go doctor with the liver go
doctor where's the green one go and one
away forever that's way too long settle
on that yes there we go that's out of it
but where's my other kidney where's my
other kidney oh god oh god oh god my
other kidney my other kidney did you
take my head getting away everybody oh
man
love her daughter if I don't have the
other kidney I don't care if that didn't
make any damn sense to you ah God
forever maybe if I magically open this
up no it's wrong all right I just put
the one in maybe you'll get half credit
yep yeah good okay that looks good in
there I'm so happy we did that thanks
Bob for being a dick god I gotta do it
again
okay I'm gonna go from this one from the
start because this one was amazing I
really like this tool one of my favorite
tools ever I just poke it in there and
it slices everything up it slices
everything up it slices everything oh my
god it's beautiful
I don't think I even need to get the
ribs out of there with this cuz I can
reach in okay ill oh god you intestine
so laughs what
okay maybe like an oh boy okay don't get
stuck in there mr. Toole I need you I
need you so much you don't know how much
I mean I'm just causing a traumatic
hemorrhaging right here okay just get
that stomach out ah gasps mom okay you
don't go anywhere
oh you're going somewhere but don't go
there quickly okay just
I hear that heartbeat oh I couldn't hear
it over the sound of this saw before I
guess just get out there gather you
gotta be joking me what the hell
happened oh you son of a [ __ ] yeah yeah
he's gonna die hards current current
drill to the face guy needs a serious
drill did it did it
drilled him in the face but doctor
that's how we were supposed to shut up
nurse no it's best how did I get so bad
at this I swear I was good at this at
one point I mean it is in space at all
but [ __ ] it seems like I have lost a lot
of skills that Nigerian medical school
not as good as not as good as a
Nicaraguan one I gotta say not as good I
mean you'd think that what seriously
that loan was that thick I don't cut
into his flesh he needs that flesh for
other fleshy things
laughs yes yes there we go yes yeah we
go a lot of pieces in there but I don't
think that'll matter okay don't open
that don't open that container you
didn't see it because it would behind my
face I guess but yeah things have been
sons of [ __ ]
oh yeah in the eyeball no my tool oh no
got a hurry my tool it's running away a
tool Oh holding the damn thing ah god
damn it everything's going wrong see
this this is why I don't like this game
incredible amounts of rage incredible
outstanding amounts of whoa calm down
you go down of your mind no I'm not you
are you are markiplier no I'm not
shut up this is backwards this this is
[ __ ] backwards
aah thunk help me
my guess the scalpel will have to do a
gimme oh come on actually grab onto it
did I get it right please no gotta get
it this is backwards oh man
you know it'll never happen it'll never
frickin happen when I'm playing this
game I'll never grab it the right way
this does okay this will have to do
whatever has to do I don't care just get
it in there man yes doctor very sure you
should be holding the instruments upside
down like that nurse I'm not sure what
I'm doing anymore with my life
leave me alone I'll meet you back at the
apartment later I love you I love you
shut up nurse what kind of [ __ ]
doctor am I seriously just oh okay all
right well really really really I have
nothing all my tool the tool it's back
my tool my tool we're I'm here beautiful
oh you beautiful slicer upper I don't
even know what you your technical name
but I got to readjust you so just oh
don't mess up
I'll do ya slice it up place it place it
so good place it so good doctor doc done
your new nurse I'll never tell you to
shut up nurse doctor that means so much
to me doctor you ever gonna complete
this [ __ ] surgery doctor I don't care
if I've been playing for 20 [ __ ]
minutes on the same move your damn hand
yeah laughs its blast ah ah this is
holding at the rock why this is all
wrong this is complete dude I was
looking at this how is this how's this
ah whatever
oh stop it oh I finally got it I got you
you [ __ ] bastard you bastard it gets
lice place you up likes you already
sliced that we need 2 slice more Oh No
but why is this not working it works so
many times before it works so well it
works just wasted fly seed I see mix
fight clods
oh are you kidding me is that working
this was working before I'm sweating I
am angry rage rage god damn it oh I
don't like to play this game because
it's dumb oh [ __ ] my life and go right
hell yeah I am very very angry
ignore my smile I'm very angry very
angry ah ah angry anger oh [ __ ] it what
[ __ ] [ __ ] that [ __ ] everything about
that but yeah everything about that
really this is what you want to do with
your life
really this is this is this this this
this this is correct this this right
here it's correct
that's okay if I can't even grab this
all right how many I'm gonna even get
started on this I was so close the first
time how can you possibly mess up
anymore there god damn oh my god I'm so
angry what pressure through the roof
what pressure is so high unbelievably
high can't even begin to describe how
high my blood pressure is right now I'm
sweating I'm literally sweating and
literally buddy sometimes these bones
don't take much sometimes they take an
enormous amount of persuasion I don't
get it yeah and again I don't care I
just want to get through this with my
tool that is way over here for some
reason why is it over here oh oh oh my
tool you can see it down there it is
exactly the farthest away that it could
be while I can still see it
that's just taunting me that's just
being a giant [ __ ] that's what that
is okay I'm gonna grab this one it's
gonna work
he's gonna wake me it's just taunting me
it's wanted me you talk to me this is
not correct but I don't care okay
anymore
I just gotta do it I'm just gonna do it
cuz I mean [ __ ] [ __ ] you oh god [ __ ] you
there's only one scalpel left mother of
God
this is the waste ah caress your face
why bobis is so hard why God God gotta
be [ __ ] kidding me
unbelievable is [ __ ] you now
unbelievable
desist [ __ ] okay alright okay
you dawn new day new person to kill make
you survive I don't know I don't think
anyone makes it out of these surgeries
alive to be honest this is being
perfectly honest if you don't mind my
honesty here okay
alright then good job alright no grandma
tool Oh got it
alright yeah perfect perfect orientation
for slicing into flesh perfect place oh
so easy
it's likes down deep place it up right
up
I'll go black back to that later place I
see yes the next point placed off done
yeah now why is this last one so
freaking hard okay reorganize myself yep
this is still backwards [ __ ] good to
get like this and then get out of here
get out of here I don't hear you
ah now you're closer to my ears in it
oh really really really you [ __ ] [ __ ]
you guys
oh come on can't grab anything
rabbit bad rabbit just grab it No
this rabbit [ __ ] rabbit the [ __ ]
grab it that I get it it's [ __ ]
backwoods you [ __ ]
goddamnit oh I'm so angry I'm so angry
I'll never get to the [ __ ] alien
level yes there's a [ __ ] alien level
but I gotta beat this [ __ ] level to
get to the [ __ ] alien level oh I'm so
angry okay I need to calm down because
this is really getting to me I'm [ __ ]
pissed off I'm pissed off beyond all
reason this game is [ __ ] with me and
now these goddamn intestines I did this
so much better in the beginning what the
[ __ ] happened
goddamn it goddamn it [ __ ] [ __ ] balls
balls [ __ ] Christ dude cracker huh why
is this intestine not coming out it came
out so easily before everything
basically exploded out and now I can't
even persuade it to come up now I can't
even be bothered it's like temperamental
actress [ __ ] won't come out
well come out of its closet dressing
room whatever I don't care
get them get [ __ ] ribs I don't even
know if I need to get the ribs get out
of there get out of there cut the ribs
nothing else cut the ribs in nothing
else you're not even cutting the ribs
you're that bad you're that bad at what
you do you're that bad really
this isn't doing [ __ ] no no why would it
this doesn't look very effective going
throwing fragments of bone ten miles out
of the body whatever it don't matter
whatever okay now I'm gonna grab oh no
okay are you do that I'm gonna come over
here grab my instrument I want it so
badly
oh just give it to me ah [ __ ] got it but
it's wrong again okay I'm gonna get this
you just need to
gentle then okay [ __ ] he's neither very
gentle get that ones cut now ins cut cut
thumb under here no I need to get the
large intestine out means I need to cut
down here come on bust out of there like
Gangnam style
come on gangbusters come on bust out of
there what the [ __ ]
cut cut damn it god damn it what really
really there we go god this shouldn't be
happening
oh god he's got to die where's my green
with my green just give me my green
give me my green to me no no no oh you
oh I'm so angry I'm so angry I'm so
angry I'm so angry but so angry this is
why I had to stop playing these games
cuz they made me so [ __ ] angry God
I'm beyond angry I just my for some
reason I do not do well with these games
god I'm so angry I'm so angry I'm so
beyond every every even tiny modicum of
anger is past it's past it's gone gone
yelling does not help anymore it's to
the point where I'm going to have to go
down after I'm gonna go lay down after I
played this and I'm gonna have to I'm
gonna have to just relax where's my tool
a tool has disappeared again [ __ ] why
why why would it
okay got it okay I got this very good
position place that I see the connection
point see the connection point here the
thing I do not see is the connection
point for the other end of the [ __ ]
big intestines but no there's there we
go that that just like that okay get out
of there
big intestines gather you're basically
dead so you're not gonna bleed anymore
get out get out you're not welcome here
anymore okay
finally made some friggin progress cat
stomach out all right very out Kenny get
cut you're cut from the team you're not
welcome anymore here the other kidney it
cuts your cut you're not up to standards
yeah not up to snuff you're never gonna
be nobody rock is just nobody all right
gotta stop the bleedin where's my green
that's way over there that's okay it's
gonna grab it gently gently got it
yeah in the face right in the face it's
okay
Bob here took an axe quite hard to the
face but he's okay kidney oh my god
kidney don't go anywhere
oh please don't go anywhere I've almost
got this one oh my god Oh get out of it
yeah stay away oh my god that kidney is
oh my god then they and they [ __ ]
n-no no yes yes no don't that close you
were gonna close [ __ ] any emergency
but whose ah who got that got it
stay down until you settle in there yeah
ah [ __ ] you
really you [ __ ] okay just know you're
coming up why you should just dentally
behen
no that's out that's out why are you out
this was handled sad [ __ ] that in that's
staying in that's coming out see you see
you there
stand [ __ ] man back blast and a goal
keeper now that's all I do
putting kidney goalkeeper all right then
back to the actual [ __ ] surgery give
me that give me that liver no I'll give
me that liver ah I give me that lawyer
hey wait you still there I see you
floating there you stay stay okay that
liver yeah give me oh no no no get
higher well what do you think you do
what do you think you do hey get back in
there you're not out get down you got
five to ten No oh my god everything is a
disaster call gone wrong get back in
there I'll need you soon very soon just
I know you're antsy I just gotta get
this kidney out of here alright that's
fine now okay
it's your turn your time time to shine
oh it's going it's going oh my god it's
going oh my god no
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh that's the liver god
damn it oh that's a dead one is that the
dead one is the dead one [ __ ] the
[ __ ] box it was in my fingertips it
was in my hand
it just [ __ ] vanished I have one last
last-ditch attempt that is a dead one oh
no that's the liver again god damnit
liver stop tricking me
okay why are the dead ones floating
around the dead ones are here [ __ ] I'm
gonna try one last thing i'ma throw
objects around or I'm never gonna be
able to grab them because I can't
[ __ ] grab anything throw them around
let's see if that helps maybe I can
knock the kidney it's floating it's you
know it's floating oh I can't grab
everything I can't grab [ __ ] anything
[ __ ] oh god I'm so angry I'm so [ __ ]
angry I'm so angry
I'm so angry just go just go get out of
here dad ears [ __ ] go go I could
knock things a million miles an hour
before but now when I want to I can't
[ __ ] knock a stupid goddamn thing
yeah just give me another kidney come on
I just need one chance one more oh
that's a live one that's a live one oh
my god
oh my god that's the live one ah
so I have it we go magic trick no god
damn it mother [ __ ] humpers [ __ ]
balls
[ __ ] ass [ __ ] it's there I have it
god damn it what the [ __ ] that's
leverage to there [ __ ] you know oh my
god I'm gonna kill myself I'm going kill
myself this is absolutely unbelievable
it's unbelievable I had it I had like 15
times
god dammit why is it not [ __ ]
knocking around that's a dead one don't
you can't fool me everything's like
locked up in this corner why why get out
here
move knock it oh hey the guy he's still
alive kind of maybe dammit so mad so mad
so mad that's a live one get mirror give
me give me give me give me off oh my god
I'm gonna make it
why are you stuck [ __ ] you I did it okay
that wasn't that bad oh [ __ ] [ __ ] damn
it
[ __ ] hell [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] god I gotta
get all the [ __ ] out [ __ ] I'm sweating
so much you guys don't understand how
angry these games maybe I'm gay I get
physically physically angry like I I
gotta go lay down like today I'm done
for the rest of the day I can't do
anything else - I gotta go [ __ ] lay
down and I gotta go to sleep or I can't
go to sleep because I'm so mad at myself
and this stupid-ass game you saw
100% [ __ ] everything that I was
doing was not wrong this came and
[ __ ] [ __ ] and I'm gonna kill
everyone who made it well not really but
I mean help myself but not really
I would kill a bug I seen at the flyby
I'm gonna kill him dead
swarm I do didn't need to kill a bug not
a one anything but there were no one
cares about bugs
so anyway come on done here looks like I
was hoping to get both the kidney in the
brain level done in one but now that
wasn't gonna happen
what was I thinking I'm stupid I should
have known that I would've been a giant
idiot but whatever I don't matter who
cares
I don't okay whatever fly away thank you
all so much for watching if you wanna
see more it'll be here eventually
sometime well thanks again well see you
in the next video bye
that's okay I don't need it good
I just need to be able to store
volunteers
Oh
yeah